I think what is going to happen is this
first of all the distractions we've seen
to this independent group we're only the
start of a process quite a lot more
Labour MPs and a few more Conservative
MPs are going to defect this has
probably been an arrangement set up in
advance and I imagine that what you're
going to see is a steady stream of
defections this is being done for media
management purposes is to keep the story
in headlines over time that's how it's
actually organized
unfortunately so so that's what it's
going to happen now the context for all
these splits in Parliament at the moment
is that we can't have a general election
because the fixed term Parliament act
which means that you need two-thirds of
MPs to vote for a general election and
there's always going to be at least a
third of parliament at the moment who
don't want a general election for the
good reason that they fear they'll lose
their seats so there isn't going to be a
majority for dissolving Parliament's at
the moment plus you could do it with a
no-confidence vote but as recent events
have shown even if the government has
lost its majority there's still a
majority who think that they do not want
Jeremy Corbyn to be Prime Minister and
so she's not going to lose a confidence
vote so we aren't to have a general
election at the same time we have a hard
legal deadline for leaving the EU on the
29th of March and that basically means
that Parliament has become a pressure
cooker and all the divisions within the
parties are becoming more and more
intense and it's leading both of the
parties to fracture and the emergence of
quite distinct groups in Parliament
which I think will become the
parliamentary wings of two new parties
effectively certainly one new party
maybe two because it's interesting
you're talking about all of this and and
but there is a party out there that is
broadly centrist profanes no one joining
the Lib Dems that's that's a very good
question and I think it's partly because
they still haven't gotten over the for
them near-fatal experience of being in
coalition with the Conservatives they
should have learned from history
whenever the Labour Party the Liberal
Party rather has historically gone into
coalition or supported one of the other
two parties it's been the kiss of death
and I think they still haven't gotten
over that plus they have the problem
that they have a number of outstanding
MPs but nobody who's in really prominent
leadership role who ticks that box of
really appealing to a white bar to the
public they don't have any any leaders
left who are still comfortable with gay
sex so how big is this independent group
going to be two or three months for my
auditing I think it could be about forty
to fifty members of parliament mmm I
would not be surprised though it may be
I would say we're probably going to see
about another twenty Labour MPs leave
and another nine or so conservative MPs
so several of torreón fees like Nick
Bowles have said that they're basically
waiting to see how votes go on various
practices amendments in Parliament but I
think that's pretty much certain he's
dead I'm gonna wake the other way he
wants to them to and therefore he's
going to leave and I think this is true
of quite a number of other enemies what
what would the breaks at play in this
was it the catalyst or was this always
going to happen I think that this
realignment was always going to happen
but brexit was the catalyst and the lit
that's a very good analogy because in
chemistry a catalyst is a substance that
speeds up a reaction but isn't actually
involved in the reaction and that's
exactly what breakfast has done it's
made the realignment of British politics
around nationalism versus
cosmopolitanism happen much more quickly
than otherwise would have done and
brexit and how you feel about leave or
remain is a kind of proxy for a whole
lot of other issues issues and feelings
about identity a very revealing poll
you'll find this entertaining perhaps
about levers and remainders was to ask
them what their favorite brands were and
the favorite levers brands were things
like Hovis Bisto HP sauce Heinz baked
beans a whole list of quintessentially
1950s traditional British brands the
favourite brands have remained voters
were things like uber apple imac a whole
range of very de Jour modish trendy
brands that tells you a huge amount
which is that the division between
remain and leave is actually just the
expression of a much deeper if you like
cultural divide which is partly a
division between old and young partly
between north and Midlands and the south
partly between professional and
university educators and traditional
working class or middle class a whole
series of social and cultural divisions
like that it's you talk about the
divisions I always try and think how are
we gonna heal these divisions well
that's what politics is about
realignments of this kind take place
every 40 years or so so we had one in
the 1880s 1885 to 1893 we had one in the
1920s 20 1922 to 31 we had one in the
1970s and early 80's
each time you have a realignment
initially politics is very very bitter
that's because the new issue is one that
people have it's fresh people are very
divided by it
there isn't much center ground but what
the democratic political process does is
over time over 10 20 years or so the
sort of business and starkness of that
division is ameliorated and actually you
do get the emergence of a center I'm
actually quite excited as someone who's
horrified by the extremes on both sides
which seem to be to have kind of got
hold of the microphone recently and
there they are the ones that are getting
all the attention both on the left and
on the right I'm quite excited about the
idea that you have a new centrist force
emerging on the one hand on the other
hand I look at these the people who are
forming this group and it seems to me
like the number one driving force behind
them their motivation in terms of
creating this is really these are people
who are vehemently opposed to brexit
that's what's forced them to leave their
parties and as we were talking just
before we started that's not necessarily
a very centrist now point of view so so
it's a party that's allegedly in the
sense of or it's a group for now that's
allegedly in the center but it's not
actually
you
[Music]